oh mein gott oh mein gott ich hab ein
bisschen angst
das war ein bisschen vielleicht zu
heftig direkt 1000 hallo ich meine
lieben freunde herzlich willkommen
zurück zu einer weiteren folge minecraft
hero mal ganz alleine hier auf dem hexer
tirol server und zwar ohne irgendeine
andere person ganz gechillt es regnet
das auf jeden fall megageil der könig
fordert tribut ich will zwei electric sn
zu sehen habe ich ihm was weggenommen
habe ich dem 2 habe ich dem elektriker
sense weggenommen habe ich immer etwas
weggenommen
ich war jetzt nicht ich klemme mal eben
hier ganz normal ganz kurz meine sachen
sind alle meine sachen hin letzte mal an
gehabt oder hab ich irgendwie habe ich
drauf gepackt habe ich respekt ich bin
um soft die suche gehen nach ich wollte
mir einen skill rüstung machen eine
komplette frei
da habe ich schon mal den skill himmel
hell mit und die scale boots wir haben
übrigens seeger also erst mal ich möchte
auf ein thema eingehen und zwar das
mache ich jetzt ganz kurz bevor ich
jetzt weitermache und zwar der hat das
hier einfach abgebaut der kräfte darf
das gar nicht abbauen
das ist ein regelverstoß danach start
nicht einfahren
das ist mein haus gewittert ja sogar
richtig night vision mehr gar keine
petersburger kein shader drin ja meine
lieben freunde die sache ist jetzt ist
das überhaupt der richtige
das sieht alles auf einmal so komisch
aus hier seitdem ich einmal hier mit
denen hier in der kleinen
auseinandersetzung war sich irgendwie
jeder jeden irgendwie total besten
sehr komisch vielleicht weil es gerade
regnet vielleicht muss der regen auf ihn
ist es besser
nein ich möchte mit euch über ein thema
reden und zwar das bewegt sich immer mal
ab und zu komme was bewegt sich man
kennt noch nicht welche mit euch über
das thema reden kontakt zu einer posse
das hatte den titel genommen das ist ja
nicht weiter schlimm allerdings ist es
bei euch sage ich jetzt mal ich spreche
jetzt aber ihr sprecher ist allerdings
nur die leute an die halt wirklich mega
mega leicht zu beeinflussen sind wir
fast das dann direkt so böse auf das ist
für uns alles nur sein spiel für uns ist
das nicht so dass wir so sagen okay wir
hatten jetzt die andere person weil die
mich in dem spiel getötet hat das ist
für uns nicht so ich liebe den den er
liebt mich und wenn ihnen weiterhin
videos zusammen auf und das ist alles
mega chillig bei uns nur alle anderen
leute unter meinen videos meinen jetzt
so ja ich lass das jetzt einfach mal so
rektor 1 keine ahnung
alle anderen meinen jetzt übrigens ich
habe wieder kommt echt mal bad honnef
man das thema zu ende allemal jetzt
irgendwie sehr konkrete [ __ ] und du
bist ein bussi also erstmal die sicht
aus meiner position aus meiner lage
ich pack das jetzt einmal daran jetzt
halt einfach die dass ich war wollte
eine tolle aufnahme mit denen ich habe
gesagt ich möchte keinen stress mit dir
ich will hier nicht irgendwie in streit
geraten oder sowas möchte einfach nur
mit ihr aufnehmen paar dungeons mache
ein bisschen rumlaufen bisschen treffen
bestand den lagern angucken bisschen so
was machen halt und irgendwann hat den
hat er mich einfach die ganze
abgeschossen und so was alles und dann
dachte ich mir einfach okay wenn nämlich
die ganze zeit ab schießt da habe ich
jetzt ich hatte echt total angst weil
ich hatte zwei herzen und ich habe ihm
gesagt schießen hatte ich aber endlich
abgeschafft nicht aber bis jetzt nämlich
untergetauchte weiter auf mich
geschossen
und wenn ich dann gestorben wäre hätte
ich mich auch mega aufgeregt denn dann
lässt komplett anders gewesen weil dann
werden alle gegner gewesen was ich
allerdings nicht gewollt hätte
jetzt ist allerdings so gekommen dass
ich dann halt weggelaufen bin das den am
hinterher gekommen ist weil wir endlich
fit gewesen wären ich habe ihn dann
verstarb gesagt ich bin zu hause und
habt ihr da alleine gelassen obwohl er
trotzdem die ganzen land stark gemacht
haben sich eigentlich mehr wohl gefühlt
da hinten
es hat mir irgendwie noch hinterher
gekommen und wollte mich dann unbedingt
töten und
dann habe ich ihm tausend mal gesagt
okay den letzten streit willst bezahlten
streitbare bla bla bla bla und er wollte
es dann auch unbedingt und dann gegen
ende hin habe ich dann gesagt okay wenn
du unbedingt jetzt im streit haben
willst dann ist es schon halb kaputt der
hersteller nicht gut wenn du unbedingt
jetzt irgendwie ein streit haben willst
und irgendeine auseinandersetzungen dann
können wir das von mir aus gerne machen
aber beschwerlich dann nicht wenn du
spielst aber werde er so ok und annahme
halt gemacht haben anhalt direct die
getötet nahezu es halt direkt
weggelaufen ist auf jeden fall ein
spannender kampf und nicht und ich hab
dann dementsprechend halt gewonnen und
dann meinte denen auch noch zu mir sowas
wie ja die elcom kraft dass ein postino
welche diese gesagt er würde der regel
das ist ganz einfach eine trickot im
kampf einfach sagen gibt so regelt aber
musste den ja nicht auf deswegen dass
ein wechsel an heft mich es gibt doch
die regel erklärte mich töten können
aber wir haben das zum beispiel vorher
abgemacht dass wir uns nicht gegenseitig
führt nämlich ganz abgeschlossen da war
ich halt ein bisschen traurig treffer
habe ich noch etwas meinem rucksack drin
eigentlich doch ja oder nein habe ich
nicht auch gut ja ich musste mich gerade
mal wieder so ein bisschen aus
hackenbroich auch mal wieder
dementsprechend finde ich eigentlich
dass den und ich mehr oder weniger fit
sind und das ganze hätte ich auch nie so
hochgeschaukelt hätte da nicht als titel
genommen hier konkret ab meine meinung
hat er als titel genommen das war jetzt
ein paar fakten zu viel hier und ich
möchte da ich keinen vorwurf machen das
ist nur die leute interpretieren das
immer direkt so als wie zwischen und so
die wollen das als brief haben mehr oder
weniger die wollen das einfach als die
haben das ist ein bisschen traurig also
wir kommen super miteinander klar wir
werden auch wahrscheinlich heute noch
was zusammen aufnehmen was anderes habe
ich nicht gold ich habe kein gold hier
noch ein gold ich habe zwei gold war was
brauche ich noch das brauche ich da zwei
gott das 25
sodann kann ich mir noch eine rose
machen so da kommt später obsidian
reihen bekommt de
sodann wenn wir uns richtig ran halten
kriegen eventuell diese folge noch eine
scale aber ich bin nicht sicher ob wir
das schaffen
ender transport und ich hab die
nachwuchs seinen dank für das falsche
entscheidung weil einfach kein bisschen
dankbar war
ich habe ihm alles zurückgeben die
beatniks zurückgegeben ich habe alles
gegeben hat eine komplette scale-up
haben können und keiner ist mir dankbar
alle beleidigen mich ich dachte jetzt
alle meinen so höhe dieser versucht dass
du noch mal angefangen hast aber allem
ein wiederkommen crafter ist der böse
mann das ist finde ich ein bisschen
traurig ehrlich gesagt ich habe mir
versucht alles richtig zu machen und ich
wurde nur abgeschossen und so wollten
zurückschlagen
dann habe ich wieder eins aufs maul
bekommen und dann habe ich ihn einfach
getötet obwohl er nicht töten wollte und
ich verstehe das nicht
ich verstehe es nicht alle meine kraft
der bilder macht all 4 kg und wo ich
habe ja noch bodyshaping vermindert auf
ich habe übrigens noch so enchanted book
paderborn aber das bringt nichts ich
möchte nur meine zauberstab jetzt mal
verzaubert und ich weiß gar nicht wie
ich das mache ich gehe damit jetzt
einfach mal hier zu kämpft damit und
sonst müssen wir auch gleich auf eine
reise und zwar das erstmal zu dem thema
du penner gange waren das wissen gesicht
bekommt nichts tut dem könig statt ding
für dein leben höhle sei ich könnte
meine hand dafür ins feuer legen dass
das reh wie wache do.com stadtpartei of
fame kann ich jetzt kostenlos verzaubern
enchanted kostet nix alter kost alles
nix vorteil also ich hab ich bin echt so
froh dass ich hier leute in bei mir in
der community aktiv wir so was alles war
das sieht schön aus mit dem ring aber
das geil ist wir können nicht schlafen
gehen und dann hoffentlich der regen mal
auf ich finds echt geil dass ihr so eine
geile community seitdem wurden so viele
fans geschrieben also fuhr ich noch
gesagt ihr seid scheiß aber das sind
halt ist echt viele leute auch drunter
geschrieben ja jetzt hat der regen auf
zumal viele leute wirklich drunter
geschrieben ja conny ich verstehe warum
gebetet wirst du hast den alle sachen
zurückgegeben aber ja das ist schön dass
es ruhig und cool und du hast den er die
sachen zurück gegeben und was alles hat
super reagiert und dann meinen hier alle
ein paar leute meinen dann wieder kacke
übrigens dass man auch welche das ich
habe wieder meinen hexe pläne natürlich
könnt ihr ganz ganz viele tipps
schreiben da meinen ich sollte stieler
drauf packen weil wir nicht mit dem
living metal dance for the mentalist
einsehen material
wenn ich damit jetzt mops schlage
repariert sich das schwert immer so ein
bisschen geht auf jeden fall nicht
kaputt da sind scheiben kaputt
das meinten einige steel 3 das habe ich
jetzt drauf so haken zauberstäbe kann
man kostenlos verzaubern und schoki ist
hinter cavs haus im portal dass man auch
sehr viele dass mein erstes jockey dass
mein zweites talkie zwar von tim getötet
wurde wartet dass es gerade nötig möchte
ich schlage jetzt einfach hier mit kurz
hatte dann komme ich vielleicht ein paar
seelen hier oder wo kommentiert seelen
hinter olio das ist geil war zwar hat
als er das ist gut und das sind jetzt
die ganze säle die können wir mit
solchen geräten aufsammeln aber das ist
jetzt erst mal relativ unnötig weil ich
ja jetzt will die metal dance world cup
die sache ist dass der mega geil wenn
die mal so richtige herzen gruppen
lassen
also warte mal was das lassen jeder soll
es klappen
irgendwas wertvolles auf nichts
wertvolles emerald gehen noch so aber
sonst nichts aber dieses skelett für
solche monster fallen ist das echt so
geil digger also einige meinen dass
jackie never ist also mein erstes coupé
das zweite wurde vom team während des
falls getötet aber das erste ist
angeblich darüber noch im netz vorhanden
dass ich mir dass da wieder so abholen
kann
schlechte nachricht meinte ein user gute
nacht ist es im märz schlechte
nachrichten okay doch was ist angeblich
es hat wohl in einer versteckt oder ich
weiß nicht wie genau das alles da
passiert ist aber ich hoffe mal dass es
noch irgendwo da ist ich mach das mal
ganz kurz wieder zu ich musste noch im
töten hier tut mir leid
es soll wohl irgendwo im netz weil ich
denke ich hoffe ich finde das auch
selber habe ich als irgendein bogen rat
fallen lassen punch punch es waren auch
welche das hier angeblich legia bögen
drin sein und so was alles aber nein das
stimmt natürlich nicht
beim feilen kann ich auch hier rein tun
dass man auch wieder ganz viele dass
hier angeblich eben wie living metal
ganz okay jetzt einfach ein living metal
james ward drin und rektor als ward
strecken reizwort nehme ich mir dürfen
sie alles nehmen was hier drin ist okay
das ist geil
ich dachte ich habe euch eigentlich
nicht geglaubt dass hier living hätte
james watson sind weil wir ja okay außer
kfd schon gute sachen hat aber ich hätte
nicht gedacht ist es da noch drin liegt
wie für eine facetime ist ein bisschen
und fokussiert das ist auch sehr gut
dass mir das ganze nach zehn minuten
auffällt sagt dir denn ich kenne meinen
kommentare schreiben und fokussiert ist
habe ich schon alle sowie bei der aktion
mit der höhe konkrete entwicklung
ermöglicht die abonniert du [ __ ]
spaß die dinos der beste so was an
welche das ist nichts gegen denen aber
dass etwas gegen die leute aber ich bin
froh dass die jetzt wechseln ich hoffe
dass die ehrlich gesagt nicht
wiederkommt sonstiger musste draufpacken
so kann ich das nicht da drauf packen so
täter jetzt hab ich so stieler 2 habe
ich nur
so stiehler 5 entscheidend ist der 5 das
habe ich gerade ausgepackt nix hftl ftc
fest dass das dass nach dem tod noch ab
hier habe ich und so steelers das dass
sie sich selbst repariert irgendwie muss
ich auch mit meinen scale sachen auf
jeden fall noch machen
ich mache erst mal die schuhe 112
entscheidenden dingsbums kostet warte
mal wenn ich doch etwas den zauberstab
den habe ich doch als eigentlich da hab
ich doch an breaking drauf etc
ich achte jetzt mal unten darauf wie
schnell der weg geht
der erde gelten mega schnell weg liga
schnell da brauch ich ja richtig viel
electrical tänzen und ich habe noch zwei
geben ich weiß nicht warum habe ich
kenne ihn laster abgezogen theorie zieht
auch geradeaus mit diesen vor allem
irgendwie lag dass hier überhaupt nicht
bei mir ich brauche einfach eins ab okay
aber das doch relativ frisch so ich
hoffe jetzt mal ich denke ich müsste
eigentlich hier mit hier reinkommen oh
mein gott oh mein gott oh mein gott mein
kopf ich habe ein bisschen angst
das war ein bisschen vielleicht zu
heftig direkt 1000 doch war
wahrscheinlich war aber meine meine mom
eine rüstung ist ja auch nicht voll
ich muss er hexie carl dinger finden und
gold scheiße da muss ich jetzt auf jeden
fall gegen die höhle mal reingehen kacke
das eisen ich muss gold film das egal
wenn es ihnen die sondern krieg gibt die
den goldrausch sortiert pinguine
ich habe mir das schreiben auch leute
die ich innerhalb konya den falschen
bogen geben der panel machen eh was sie
wollen ziemlich auseinander bringen das
ist wie folco ich habe keine pfeile
vollpacken wie von ein paar leuten
ich hab den nicht den falschen bogen
gegeben hat ich hatte den ja auch
gefunden den dialog mit den gleichen
verzauberungen den hatte ich ja zwei mal
und einen davon habe ich dir immer
gegeben da war genau die gleiche
verzauberung darauf habe ich extra
darauf geachtet das ist ein bisschen
traurig dass die leute hier so gegen das
projekt wirken sag ich jetzt mal so wenn
ich jetzt direkt nach unten laufen
müsste eigentlich meinen stadt sein soll
ich da reingehen das nicht machen ich
habe mich schon mal verlassen fällt mir
grad so auf aber ich war hier noch nicht
fertig darin fällt mir auch gerade auf
um eine rüstung ist nicht voll alter das
ist auch so ein bisschen kacke woher
liegen dass ein paar sachen formieren
weil der tank nicht so ich gucke mal wie
stark diese
die sind ja nicht daher es schaffe ich
glaub ich sogar noch mit diesem kecken
reizwort nach eine crew jetzt einfach
eine kuh hier ist nix nix ich möchte nur
so ein paar tanzen hier so abstauben
am besten halt electric essenzen damit
ich mir dass diese flugzeuge stäbe
machen kann
ich weiß auch gar nicht geht es hier
allgemein gehen wie kommt ihr noch
irgendwas heftiges bleibe ich quasi das
heftigste schon entdeckt dass das hier
mein gott alter das macht er richtig
wenig schaden mit dem scheiß schwert da
muss sich doch erstmal suite schnell wie
viel macht er mir denn der schaden wenn
der mich einmal angreift auch nur ein ja
dann locker idee alter natürlich dann
schafft es der isi also das waren
einfach so die einzigen aussagen die ich
jetzt mal ganz kurz jeden tätigen wollte
in diesem video würdigt ihr das essen
in diesem video und zwar ging es halt
wirklich darum dass er hat einen tollen
hielt zauberstab das ist geil ich hoffe
den kriege ich wenn der tod ist und zwar
geht es mir halt echt nur darum dass man
mich nicht jetzt irgendwie als pussy
darstelle dass mich jetzt nicht
irgendwie alle hast oder so wegen der
aktion ich finde ich bin sogar im recht
aber da so war da sollte jeder seine
eigene meinung darüber bilden möchte nur
nicht dass ich da irgendwie zu unrecht
beleidigt werden und irgendwie blöd da h
mancher kommt dessen angst weil ich
meine rüstung einfach nicht komplett ist
das bereitet mir echt ein bisschen angst
nicht einmal akw kommen immer noch ein
anderes mal hin und freunde so electric
stuff ist gleich kaputt
ich hab ja eigentlich an breaking drauf
aber ich weiß nicht warum das dann so
schnell kaputt geht dann kann ich
irgendwie reparieren oder und schreibt
dass man die kommentare ich nehme jetzt
nur eine folge auf ihr keine tipps
schreiben bezüglich verzauberung für
meinen little giants worte das ist nicht
so schnell kaputt geht
ich meine ich habe ja an breaking glaube
ich drauf an breaking 3 und 5 sogar also
eigentlich müsste das ja eigentlich ganz
gut funktionieren
das ist auch so schöne irgendwie so mit
den bällen und das war die beste
entscheidung cher einzupacken das
richtige höhle schreibt mir einfach
irgendwas in die kommentare wurde vorbei
apropos will ich noch mal irgendwann
seine brauche ich nehme das jetzt am
besten direkt mal mit die höhe geht
sogar noch weiter ich habe echt ein
bisschen angst wenn ich laufe hier immer
so rein um eine um eine rüstung ist
einfach nicht vor dass ein bisschen
traurig naja schreibt mir das einfach in
die kommentare so ein paar stücke wie
ein paar tipps und tricks bezüglich
verzögerungen auf so ein paar sachen das
ist hier alles kein gold das ist traurig
weil ich brauche gold oder das ist auch
kein gold
hier war grad irgendwas was auch geil
war schon geil
er warnt auch gold auf auf welcher höhe
gold wieviel bräuchte nicht auf 5 dass
das ist letztlich auch das ist einfach 4
es ist einfach nur vier grad fand ich
brauche noch ein gold irgendwo mein gott
da brauchen wir noch eine extension als
alles prima und dann haben wir unsere
scale arme und wir haben keine wir haben
uns bisher alles selbst kräftig wir
haben uns nichts auch halo haben uns
bisher freunde da bin ich ja auch so
stolz sein denn wir müssen und nichts
schenken lassen wir ihm dem megaprojekt
ich musste noch nicht unbedingt
irgendwie beibringen lassen oder
irgendwie sowas heftiges das ist echt
alles nur durch eure hilfe entstanden
was mega geil ist ihr letzter zeit ist
zwar das verhältnis zwischen mir und
euch so ein bisschen gestresst jetzt
durch die aktion auch so aber allem
allem im groben genommen finde ist
megageil dass wir alle das hier so alles
zusammen machen meine lieben freunde das
wenig unterscheidet uns ein bisschen so
von kanälen die das alles zu
hintereinander rattern
jetzt ist jetzt aber ein bisschen dunkel
in der nacht ich bin nicht so schlecht
ist wie es die stadt als unterstand
aber wir nehmen den electric sa firmen
juhu
so ich dir noch eben verzaubern kann das
ist so geil mit dem electrics darf man
das so mein gott man ist so unglaublich
schnell
also ich mach das jetzt mal einfach auf
ihre mein gott mal schauen fühlt sich
das irgendwie auch da unten muss mein
schwert hin wo ist mein schwert hin wo
ist mein schwert hin muss man stört hin
oh mein gott erschwert den an wenn ihr
mich anbetrifft wenig tut um mein gott
da sind so viele zombies dass ihm was
heftige skat entstanden unter mein gott
oh mein gott ich habe angst angst angst
die klauen meine waffen irgendwie ich
habe angst ich will erstmal schlafen
oh mein gott habe ich angst alter die
haben mir da drin meine sachen geklaut
de guardia mehrfach mit wachen geklaut
einfach meine sachen geklaut alter die
haben mir einfach mein schwert und so
geklaut und wenn er das nicht wieder
drobny banker herztod jetzt ausgestanden
alter
viel angst vor denen gerade die banken
da schon raus jetzt werdet ihr sterben
dies galt auch kaputt mein gott es
regnet erfahrung mit erfahrung
ja ich will diese scheiß ich werde jetzt
aus machen da ich hab da galt echt mega
angst vor weil ich immer wieder schaden
bekomme durch die alle jetzt bin ich
auch noch vergiftet hier alter wie mega
kacke ist das denn bitte gerade wie
kriege ich die dann denn jetzt tot
der eine hat sogar meine geile schwert
in der hand
aber das ist da oben jetzt gestoppt das
ist schon mal ganz gut das heißt noch
die töten jedoch nie drin sind dann ist
alles gut aber das auch schon heftige
skelett gerade drin
das lässt sich auch nicht töten scheiße
mann und der eine hat meinen der hat man
allerdings schwert einfach manche motive
seines skelette töten
okay das eines gesetzes megapixel at&s
muss ich mich kurz
ich stelle gerade an hunger leute alte
meeting hat alles dass es so krass ich
verlier grad gegen die mobs junge wie
ihre ist das denn ich muss das nicht ich
mache jetzt kurzen cut und dann nämlich
nächsten folge direkt weiter auf ihr
meine lieben freunde sind an der
nächsten folge wenn ihr uns